so hi everybody my name is Tanya Morelli
and I work at Arcadia power and we are a
sponsor of this conference and you
probably have been hearing us a whole
bunch and wondering like who we are so
I'm excited to tell you guys who we are
but before I start I want to tell you
another story of how I got this job so
last year I was sitting at this
conference in the audience like all you
all and this guy max Richman who's
actually sitting right over there came
up and gave a talk and at the time I was
sitting in the audience and I was in a
place of transition I had just finished
graduate school I had been working at
the Department of Energy for three years
and at the Department of Gia
I was forecasting US crude oil
production using SAS and so at this time
I kind of wanted to have a different job
and there were two things that I really
wanted in my next job one in grad school
I have learned that ARS amazing so I
really wanted to be able to do analysis
and R and to I wanted to not work in oil
and work in renewables and so max comes
up starts giving this talk about this
cool company called Arcadia power and
start telling us all about how he
actually uses sequel he don't really
talk about are Mikey likey through or
into it a little bit and I just assumed
that they use R and I was like wow I
want that job so just like Jarrett's
been telling all of you guys if you go
and say hi to someone I don't know you
might end up having a job so here I am a
year later I work at Arcadia power I
love my job and I'm really excited to be
here to talk to you guys about
renewables reproducibility and arm work
down let's jump in after that warm and
fuzzy introduction let's talk our
climate change so this is how I feel
about climate change um it's fine it's
great so I think one of the issues that
I personally have with climate change is
that it's this huge like existential
crisis it's like doom and destruction is
coming
get you and all of us as like
individuals so it feels like there's not
very much that we can do to resolve it
like sort of how Elizabeth earlier
talked about you could reduce your meat
consumption so that's that's one thing
but when it comes to your electricity
like we are a society that depends on
electricity we have to use electricity
and unfortunately most of our
electricity currently is sourced from
fossil fuels which are putting carbon
and methane and all these wonderful
things at the atmosphere and it's
eventually going to have us all die and
that's like and so so it sucks it feels
like you don't have a lot of agency over
this this huge issue so that's something
that Arcadia Power is trying to resolve
so we are kind of in the business of
giving people agency over there
there are electricity powered decisions
so we do this by giving you access to
clean energy and we do this through
matching it your usage to renewable
energy credits also known as recs and we
believe that choose and clean energy
shouldn't be something that causes you
to have to pay more money like it
shouldn't be a premium thing it should
be something that everyone should have
access to so with that without ethos we
match 50% of your usage to renewable
energy credits completely for free and
then to get to 100% we have a small
premium and that's that's one thing
another way that we help give access of
clean energy to two people is through a
community solar program and we do that
the community solar program is important
because a lot of people like I'm sure we
would all love to have solar panels on
our roof but the reality is they're very
expensive and a lot of times we are
renters or we live in places where the
Sun doesn't exactly shine at the right
part of our house it's feel to put a
solar panel there and so instead to get
access to solar energy you can get
access to solar community solar projects
through Bristol net metering and so and
also by doing that you can lower your
energy bill by getting credits back
your bill for what those solar farms
produce so we give access to customers
through that completely for free and
then the third thing that we do which is
not strictly about clean energy but it
it falls under the idea of energy
shouldn't be clean energy shouldn't be
something that's more expensive is we
have a smart rate program and with our
trick program in the regulated States so
most of the Northeast where you have the
option to choose your energy supplier we
kind of work as a broker to help you
find the lowest rates to your energy so
you can lower your power bill and also
try and get clean energy so it's a cool
it's a cool business the cool software
we're sort of like in this weird
in-between place over we're not a
utility company we're like a tech
company but we're like trying to like
solve this big like energy problem and
it's super easy you can sign up in two
minutes
that's my plug moving on so I work on
the analytics and data science team at
Arcadia power and our team has four main
roles we do a lot of the operations
support so that's like supporting the
product team and the marketing team and
like kind of any any of the operational
teams and making sure they have all the
data access and data needs met to run
the business we do a lot of business
analytics for making like keeping track
of things like attrition and I don't
like how many wrecks people have bought
and just big big picture business things
and then we do a lot of market research
and so that's something that I
personally work in quite a bit the
energy industry is like this huge thing
like when people talk about the grid
it's like what is the grid it's like
this big this big thing and so we spent
a lot of time trying to understand the
energy industry and understand where we
fit and where the need is and how we can
meet that need and so along that we also
do a lot of prototyping of different
products and new products before they're
put into production to make sure that
we're meeting the right customers and
getting them things they need so we do
this using a variety of tools some of
them are right here so we do a lot of
data warehousing is done in Amazon
redshift and post car sequel we use
tableau for a lot of business analytics
I would love that to be like our maybe
one day we'll get there
unfortunately you can't ever escape
Excel so we do use a little Excel and
then we also use especially for our a
lot of market research stuff weasel our
use a lot of our and a lot of our studio
so the reason I bring this up is on as a
data scientist and someone that works on
a data science team having a like a
workflow or a set of analysis that's
reproducible is something that we really
care about so what is reproducibility
when I think about reproducibility I
think about it in three different
perspectives so the first one is the
philosophical perspective and this is
something that I think we all talk about
it's like the the idea of finding the
ground truth in in whatever in your
respective fields and whatever you're
trying to do like the scientific method
is kind of based on this like
philosophical idea of reproducibility so
that's great we should we should aim for
that but something I think we don't talk
about enough is operational
reproducibility and so by that I mean
the idea of having a workflow that is
optimized and scalable and easy to
iterate on and having that really
reduces your your a need for a lot of
institutional knowledge of how processes
works and it makes it very easy to kind
of pick up your analysis and give it to
different people which is really great
for a business or for research or kind
of whatever you're trying to do and so
related I would say reproducibility on
the business perspective it's kind of
the idea of being able to make smart
decisions using the power of hindsight
so if you are a business a data-driven
business like we kind of call ourselves
sort of boss wordy we are making
decisions based off of our data and
based off our analysis of the data and
if it's really hard to reproduce that
analysis and you're making big like
monetary business decisions based on
that you're kind of leaving a lot of
money on the table if you can't
reproduce that so it's really important
to have reproducibility from a business
perspective as well so I'm gonna speak a
little more to the operational
reproducibility part and so one of the
things that I think we all struggle with
a little bit is operational
reproducibility and I think one of the
reasons behind it is because of like the
traditional workflow
analysis so traditionally you kind of
have different pieces of software to do
different parts of your large data
science lifecycle so you might do if you
want to get some data and say your
organization has databases you might use
redshift to do all your data querying
and then you might pull that into Excel
to do some like data cleaning and like
maybe some exploratory graphs and then
like oh I want to build a model so then
you're gonna go throw that to our build
a model and then eventually your boss is
like I want a deliverable so you're like
okay I'm gonna take all of that stuff
from rep shift and Excel and R and put
into this PowerPoint and somewhere along
that process
you'd make a valiant attempt to document
what you're doing so you do that in Word
and then you get to the very end that
you deliver your results and your boss
is like mm can you change that one thing
so now I gotta go all the way back in
this long linear process and figure out
exactly where you did the thing and then
how does that affect all the other all
the other pieces in your your flow and
while you're doing that you documenting
just becomes like a big pain so you're
like kind of stop doing that and then
you give the answer and then a month
later your boss is like hey can you do
that thing again you're like oh I don't
remember how I did that so that is the
traditional workflow now an alternative
workflow is the AR markdown workflow so
when I think about the AR markdown
workflow I think of it more of like
spokes on a wheel so instead of it being
a linear process where each bit kind of
depends on the other it's sort of more
like everything happens in one place and
when you change one thing it can kind of
naturally change all the other parts of
your full data science lifecycle so why
are work down sort of the summarize all
stages of the data science lifecycle I
keep saying that are in one place
documentation happens along the way
super easy to automate you guys probably
have also heard alive just like Malory
and a budget yesterday talked greatly to
this so I hope I don't sound like a
broken record but still it's great it
simplifies collaboration it reduces
dependency on institutional knowledge
and you can have multiple different
outputs with little pain and so when you
have all of those things together you
get reproducibility so this might be a
little elementary but I would like to
just kind of go through
how to go how to create a very easy or
markdown to show you that it is so easy
to do and it takes very little kind of
like skill and not list you can kind of
you know a few commands here and there
you can build your own our markdown and
maybe maybe you can go back and start
building our markdowns for your analysis
if that's not something that you're
doing already so this is an example of
an our markdown that I've built for an
analysis that I'm still in the middle of
doing where I'm trying to identify
predictors for residential electricity
usage and so sort of like are these
demographic things like what makes a
person's electricity bill or electricity
usage the way it is so I'm doing this
using the Energy Information
administration's residential energy
consumption survey data and I've gone
through mostly the entire process and so
I don't I don't really care about what
I'm trying to show you I kind of want to
show you how I did it so in in this our
markdown you can see that it's really
pretty I like that you can have the data
that I'm using you can show it and
Mallory showed this yesterday or it's
interactive and you click buttons it's
all there you can embed graphs which is
really cool all of the text where you're
just describing things is is all in that
document my personal favorite thing is
the floating table of contents when I
discovered how to do this a month ago I
was like oh my gosh this is
life-changing and the other thing that I
think is really cool is just like the
numbering of sections like there's ways
to do this automatically you might
already know a lot of this and then
ggplot is my favorite you can
standardize that very easily I know you
can do things like tabs and you can see
that like all parts of my analysis are
all in one place it's really nice it's
easy and when I want to make a change I
can just make the change click knit and
then the whole thing populates again so
it's great so going into some specific
features how I did that so first
formatting so this when you're creating
our markdown this is what kind of the
beginning looks like you're gonna give
your title your subtitle if you have on
the author that's me in this case and
you can define your document format so
there's the HTML document I like using
HTML document because it's really easy
to do interactive stuff and it's like
it's cool but say if you want a PDF
output or if you want a word output like
you can do all of those things just by
changing that one little thing that says
HTML document the floating table of
contents is so easy all you do is use
the TOC command in your header and you
make that true and then you get the
table contents and then you can make a
float on the side just by putting TOC
underscore float equals true so super
super easy super cool this number
sections is the in the table of contents
on the side you could see how those
sections are numbered and the cool thing
about that adding that thing is that
when you run an ad section to take away
sections the numbers will automatically
update which is which is just nice
dynamic table displays are really easy
if you just put this DF print equals
page command at the top and every every
table that you print you don't have to
even use like the knitter cable any of
that stuff it'll just come out in this
nice nice format that's cool and then
finally the document theme you can put
all these different themes I like using
the Bhoots watch themes there's so many
of them I don't know if you ever gone
here but there's a lot of really cool
themes here and I like to go in and and
you just put the name of the theme
inside of your markdown and then you can
you have your theme and that's that's
cool and I learned a lot of this from
our markdown the definitive guide which
was by Evie she and JJ Alera and Garrett
from almond and it was I it was so easy
to learn just by like reading this so I
highly encourage you to go look at it if
it's something that you if are more kind
of something that's like scary and you
haven't tried yet great resource and
then also boots watch themes are cool to
play with so when you're creating your
arm rectum so there's there's all the
formatting you can make that nice you
can do all of the writing inside of it
and then you can also create your code
so that's where this is really powerful
in creating a code chunk is super easy
you define them by these three back
ticks and if you are going to do it at
are you can put are if you're gonna do
Python which I learned yesterday
apparently you can make a Python and
then do Python inside
which is really cool I when I'm creating
markdowns
I like to put all my libraries and I'm
gonna use the analysis all inside of the
setup chunk and I do this so I can kind
of keep track of all the libraries that
I'm using at the end of my analysis and
oftentimes when I am doing analysis and
I'm like oh I need to use this other
library I'll go all the way up to the
set of chunk and stick that in there you
can set global chunk settings and so
doing that the settings are like echo
equals false and so if you set to false
then when you knit your markdown you
won't have your code output but it will
execute so that's nice and if you want
to show your code then you can make that
true so that's cool and then another
thing I like to do is standardize my
ggplot theme which you could use this a
standard a theme I like to mess with
theme so I like to make things pretty so
if you use the theme set command at the
very beginning and you set it to the
theme then all of your GG plots moving
forward will be of that theme so you
won't have to like theme set in each
each plot so that's great and lastly in
my set of chunk I like to standardize my
numerical output so I like to make sure
that there are no scientific figures and
that my significant digits are limited
so I don't have big crazy numerical
outputs text I just want to show you how
easy this is like oh what's on the right
is what is on that side the left is the
code and what's on the right is the
output and so when you put text it goes
straight into it comes out exactly the
way you write it and it also shows up in
your table of contents exactly the way
you write it so it's really easy it's
really dynamic embedding images is super
easy you just create a chunk and use the
include graphics function from the
neural package and it will output as the
exact image that you hope for and then
also doing the simple things like making
bulleted lists like that's really easy
and it's it's very intuitive so that's
one of the reasons I really like the
text part of markdown and then the other
thing I want to talk about a little bit
is the main code chunks and so
with the idea of having a really
reproducible analysis and an
organization I would say it's a good
idea to sort of like talk with your
theme with their team about how you want
to structure your code chugs and so the
nice thing about markdown is that you
can have both their back-end and your
front-end kind of in the same place so
the main back-end chunks that you would
use is your database connection if
you're doing that or your data import
query if you're doing a database and a
sort of data cleaning and then you also
have all of the front-end chunks with
your exploratory data analysis if you'd
like to make any sort of model and then
your results in session info and I think
it's well I think it's good to just talk
about this like the scenes really really
obvious like this is how anyone really
do analysis but I think like saying like
this is the way we're going to do this
and kind of setting that in an
organization is a really good way to
make sure that you have the most optimal
workflow so if I do an analysis and I
keep my analysis and I go hand it to max
for example he can look at my markdown
and know where things are gonna be and
kind of how like know how to expect my
analysis of flow and I think that's
that's a good thing to do one thing I
would really like to encourage you if
this is something that you use if you
use databases in your organization
connecting your database directly into
your markdown is really powerful and it
like truly makes your markdown the most
reproducible it could possibly be so you
eat you eliminate in addition to
eliminating things like moving like
handing graphs and analysis in different
places you eliminate the need for
handing over your initial data which is
really cool you can just throw in your
credentials the library the RO the BC
library allows you to do this you can
very easily use the driver connect
function to connect your database you
can use the sequel tables function to
list the tables in your database and
then you can query directly into inside
of a chunk and output that into a data
frame and then just use that data for
the rest of your markdown which i think
is awesome
and then finally on the front-end you
guys already know
after listening to this whole conference
like you could do lots of you can make
these plots with ggplot or whatever
you'd like and put it directly inside
your markdown and I love this so much
more than I then Excel or other
point-and-click software because when
you want to make a quick change it's so
easy to do and then lastly the session
info this is a command that I like to
put at the end of all of my markdowns it
kind of just tells you all of the like
the operating system and all the
packages and kind of all the things that
happen in the background that you used
to make sure you did your analysis or
that helped you do your analysis and I
think this is a good thing to do just
the kind of kind of keep track of what
you're using and since I mean with ours
and so many people are making different
types of packages sometimes you lose
track of what packages you're using and
so this is just like a good way to
document that so takeaways climate
change sucks when your goals are great
I don't know sign up for Arcadia power
prioritizing operational reproducibility
will improve your organization I think
if this isn't something that you're
doing already or this is something that
you want to do or markdown is a really
great tool and it really empowers you to
be a better analyst thank you yesterday
I decided that the time was ripe to
finally make a professional Twitter so
now I'm dated on yan
my first tweet had a typo in it so I'm
doing really great but yeah feel free to
reach out to me thank you
[Applause]